I'm doing it Oops, more than that Earth glass
4 me
I didn't show the one on the ring
Only the shield I'm just an outsider After all, I
just want to go back to the original world after I've done anything pe
It's okay
pe
You guys are in this world
[Applause] A
reason to use this shield That's
enough reason to defeat Glass
Ahhhhh
Sacrificing hair and screaming
is a gacha The opposite wind is created Better with my brother To know
Etna while screaming in pain
[music] rar [music]
rar
Music
] It might be a good time to think about it again
Yeah yeah yeah
-I still can't do it I
'll finish it
Oh
[music] The
game
is over Time is up So this time you guys win
What are you saying when you're 6
strokes behind?